all right at 6 36 an interactive mental
health awareness Workshop takes place at
the West Charleston library tonight
mental health professionals are going to
be on site they're going to have some
tools to help deal with mental health
challenges our youth is facing and the
goal here is to reduce suicide risk
Candace Charles joining us live this
morning with some of those tools that
could help prevent a tragedy Candace
good morning
good morning to you Heather and Good Day
Las Vegas now we all have heard about
the mental health youth pandemic that
has been combating us all and really has
been impacting Nevada as well as the
country but you know what opening
dialogue is the first step in dealing
with this and I'm joined by Rabbi
hurling of the Friendship Circle who
tends to do just that tonight at the
West Charlton library and I want to show
you something really quickly the back of
his shirt here you know look at that be
a friend it really is something that the
Friendship Circle is all about I think
it is really a first step with helping
to combat this Mental Health crisis that
we're facing correct exactly that's what
it's all about to be a friend and to
know how to properly support someone
who's struggling with special needs or
any any Mental Health Challenge we want
to be that friend you want to be that
Community to be able to be there and
support them what they're going through
their individual crisis and tonight at 6
30 come and join us we'll learn the
tools because not everyone knows you see
some of the physical disability you know
it's easy I can help them carry some
think if they've got a broken broken
bone someone who's struggling internally
with mental Mental Health Challenge we
don't always see you don't always know
what to do may feel uncomfortable what
they say what not to say so come tonight
learn those tools learn those flags you
can see if one of your friends or one of
your family members may be struggling
and let's be be that friend to support
them and make the world a better place
now I hear you will have professionals
there as well tell us really quickly
about those professionals that will be
on site a couple of the mental health
the hospitals in town some treatment
centers and the city and the county
resources are there again with Resources
with information so that you can always
reach out the thank God we're blessed
with resources here in Las Vegas so you
can reach out and get help for yourself
and for a loved one if they're
struggling so in the gallery outside the
theater tonight before the event and
after the event those Community Partners
will be there answering all questions
all right Rabbi heiling it's always good
to chat with you it's so important and
you know what this is something simple
that he wants to let people know as well
you are worth it and you can get one of
these by coming to the event tonight
they'll be raffling these off you can
also go ahead and buy it again thank you
so much for doing this for the community
it's such an important event we
appreciate all that you do and you guys
can come out to the event tonight at 6
30 at the West Charleston library for
now reporting live I'm Candace Charles 8
News Now